so Kevin the big news today the thing
that's all over the Internet is that
Microsoft has bought mojang but I mean
more specifically they bought minecraft
because that is what we know Mojang for
what did you have any specific thoughts
on this what are your feelings about
Microsoft buying well you know i'm not
i'm not a big minecraft guy by any
stretch but you know notch himself makes
out pretty good because he takes home
1.75 billion because he's a seventy
percent stable step seventy percent but
and microsoft bought them for what 2.5
billion dollars that's a lot of freaking
cash for a studio that Microsoft will
probably just run into the ground to be
fair microsomes did by air they did by
lion head which you know created the
amazing fable experience had Peter
Molyneux and then Peter Molyneux left
and there really weren't any awesome
fable experiences after that and we also
had rare which had awesome banjo kazooie
perfect dark and then Microsoft bought
them in we got kinect adventures yeah
and doesn't mean that's gonna happen to
mojang I mean they did such a good job
though with ensemble studios after Halo
Wars their very first console if it went
really really well from Microsoft's
perspective so now you should never know
what's gonna happen okay so so all
things considered obviously we don't
have great faith that Microsoft knows
what to do with uh but I think things
have changed a lot recently I mean there
are some Inklings of you know things
could go potentially terrible but I like
what they've done with the ID at Xbox
program so like that's their name for
their indie developers and you know from
talking for with the guys who are doing
Oregon the blind forest with the guys
who are doing totem like they feel like
they have a lot of freedom to kind of
create the experiences they want and
still create those games that they want
but in this case it's not even that
Mojang is really known for creating
awesome games they created a game
against it's making minecraft so really
it's just can minecraft keep its hands
off of Eric and Microsoft keep its hands
off minecraft and just keep that that
pure experience see for me the the thing
I'm orange is my we know minecraft at
this stage and it appears as though
there's probably no intention of do
something to Minecraft as it exists on
other platforms so doubtful but
Microsoft will go and just start pulling
plugs on and they said space station
yeah they want to keep it on PlayStation
they want to keep it on all the mobile
devices see for me though the question
is going to be what happens to Scrolls I
think that's for me the biggest
indicator of what Microsoft is going to
do with mojang my minecraft is just you
know it's printing money so no you know
we already know what what's going to
happen there my question is going to be
what happens with scrolls or any other
projects that mojang comes up with
that's that's to me the the deciding
factor on whether Microsoft has actually
helped mojang in any way with this with
this purchase I think the biggest
concern that people will have is are
they going to put microtransactions in
Minecraft like right now it's a big open
experience you're able to create stuff
share it out with people they keep
making free stuff that you know it's
just shared freely out there Microsoft
does like to make money they are a big
company and minecraft you know is that
it's making money on its own but it can
always make more money do you think that
they'll just go hog-wild with
microtransactions and just make this the
not play to win but this definitely
here's a base model and if you actually
want to play more you're gonna have to
front up a little more cash it's
something to be concerned about but
something tells me that right now
they're not going to be wanting to mess
with the Golden Goose I if that happens
I don't think it's gonna happen right
away and when you buy something for 2.5
billion dollars that's obviously a huge
investment they're not thinking about
this just for Xbox one that's something
the next five years like that's a 10 20
year proposition that they're putting a
lot of stock behind having that cachet
to last for lifetimes but they expect to
make the money back really fast by to
budget within one fiscal year the way to
do that is microtransactions well we'll
see where it goes Microsoft has gone
both ways they've had good stuff they've
had bad stuff I don't know where this is
gonna end up but I don't think we're
really gonna see the effects of it for
another couple year you were here first
Microsoft goes both ways
you